>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> So our next group of presenters
has been helping others work better
by developing tools,
platforms and methods
for making data collections
more accessible.
Elizabeth Lorang has been working
with the Chronicling America data
set demonstrating the potential
for collections to hold not
just answers, but also methods
for further research
returns for all.
An associate professor of humanities
and a humanities librarian
at the University of
Nebraska Lincoln.
She is also a faculty fellow
in the Center for Research
for Digital Research in
the humanities at UNL.
Her research areas include digital
humanities and digital scholarship,
American poetry and 19th
century American newspapers.
She is the Co-PI of image
analysis for archival discovery,
an NEH funded project that seeks to
leverage the information potential
of digital images for discovery
and digitized collections.
Next we're here, sorry.
Next we'll hear from Rickey
Punzalan, an assistant professor
of archives and digital curation at
the College of Information Studies
at the University of Maryland.
His research includes
understanding the relationship
of archives and collective memory.
The dynamics of digitization
in decision making
in collaborative settings,
and the uses and users
of digitized archival images.
He also examines virtual
reunification.
A strategy to provide
integrated access
to disperse ethnographic
archival images on line,
which he will speak about today.
Closing this session
is Mark Bouslog,
a developer with Universe.org,
the world's largest platform
for people powered research.
Mark focuses on developing
user interfaces
that accomplish research
previously considered impossible.
Powered by Citizen
Science and Coffee,
his recent work includes assisting
with the relaunch of Notes
From Nature, a project to transcribe
and digitize museum specimen labels.
Let's get to work and
welcome Liz Lorang.
[ Applause ]
>> All right.
Good morning everyone.
I'd like to start by thanking
the organizers and our hosts
for the invitation and the
opportunity to share my team's work
with all of you as well
as the opportunity to hear
about the projects that
you all are working on
and then the conversations
that all of us can have
over the course of the day.
The project I'll be talking about
today has been possible only
because of the contributions of
our research team past and present.
So while I'm here presenting on
our work today, I want to be sure
to acknowledge that research team.
In particular I'd like to
acknowledge my colleague at UNL,
Professor Lian Katso [SP] from
the Department of Computer Science
and Engineering, as well as my
former undergraduate student,
Grace Thomas who contributed early
on to this project in key ways.
I couldn't be more delighted
that Grace is now on the staff
of the Library of Congress
as a data specialist.
She's been here for about
a month now and also
that she's able to be here today.
So my presentation
today is in three parts.
First, a statement of a problem or
a challenge that I think we face
in working with digital collections
and in developing digital
collections.
The second part is a discussion
of an experiment of sorts
that my research team and I are
working on in order to attempt
to address that challenge
in some way.
And then the third part is a
look at the longer term and sort
of where we're headed next.
So the first part then
is this challenge
and the fundamental challenge
that we're working to address is
that for all the wealth of digitized
primary materials now available,
finding materials of relevance in
these collections remains difficult
for all but the most
routine use cases.
And this challenge is
documented most recently
by Green and Courtney in 2015.
And in their surveys and
interviews of scholars working
with digital collections of primary
materials the authors found that one
of the most prominent challenges
cited by respondents in their use
of digital collections was the
inability to search effectively
through the collection materials.
And these findings align with
those of some other studies
over the last couple of years
that similarly show the difficulty
of finding items of interest
in digital collections
and also the degree to which
more fine grained level
of descriptive detail
can be significant
to successfully analyzing corpora.
So my sense is that this
difficulty in finding materials
of relevance arises in part from
one reason is the level and degree
of description of items
in collections.
But the difficulty of finding
materials of relevance is also due
to the ways in which platforms and
interfaces shape engagement with
and circumscribe access to
materials, including the primacy
of text based searching and
barriers to bulk access.
Because even when there's an API
for most people, that's still going
to be a barrier to
access of some sort.
So addressing this challenge
of connecting people with items
of interest is going
to require efforts
on multiple and creative fronts.
In response to this challenge
my team, the image analysis
for archival discovery team is
focusing on the digital images
and collections rather than
on machine readable text.
Our work starts from
two beliefs and takes
up two questions at this point.
The first belief is that
locating relevant materials
and digital collections is
already often a difficult endeavor
and will become increasingly so
as more content is digitized.
And second that we leverage little
of the information potential
of the millions of
images that we're creating
as we digitize the cultural record.
So we're asking two questions.
What more can we do with
those millions of images
that represent the
digitized cultural record?
And what kinds of discovery
might serious attention
to these digital images yield?
Now both academic and industry
sectors are increasingly interested
in image based methods for
identification and discovery.
One significant area of
development is an image recognition
and image searching of primarily
visual works, including artwork
and contemporary mass
photography, such as photos posted
to various online platforms.
There is an increasing array of
computer vision software designed
for such applications that are
in use in academia and industry.
The emphasis, however, is very
much on images of artwork or images
of contemporary photography
or images of items
that we understand first and
foremost to be visual works.
So as my team engages with these
questions, we're interested
in turning the focus to image
analysis of textual materials.
So looking at the digital
images of textural materials.
To return to the title of my
presentation, we're interested
in what happens when we
look at text as image.
So there's a series of four slides
that attempt in a very crude
and unsophisticated fashion
to illustrate the differences
between where we are with computer
vision in contemporary photography
versus computer vision
for the purposes
of archival description
and discovery.
So the first example is an image
of a slough that I uploaded
to Google image search just
to see what I would get.
And not only were the search results
pretty highly matched to the image,
but there was also a
sense like Google knew
that what I was interested not
only was a sloth but a cute slough.
[laughs] And for me this is like the
best case scenario for image search.
I didn't have to wade through
lots of other kinds of sloughs.
I got right to the cute sloughs.
So if we contrast that with an
image of a 19th century letter.
They went through a similar process
and the results I think
are a little more varied.
The images look kind of like
the image that I presented,
but the sense of what I'm interested
in at this point is being treated
as items that are handwritten.
And we can start to see some real
potential for that to be able
within a collection to pull out
the items that are handwritten.
But what if I'm interested in
certain types of handwritten items
that haven't been described?
Here's an example quickly
of a newspaper.
In this case, again, the
recognition was pretty good.
I think in large part due
to the fact that we have
so many digitized newspapers
and digitized for microfilm.
But I want to look at this
fourth example, which is a poem
that I've cropped from a newspaper
image and now I wasn't expecting
to find lots of other
cropped newspaper poems.
Probably because I'm one of the
few people who actually does that.
There's not a huge corpus of them
at this point, but there starts
to be a pretty wide gulf here
between what is in my image
and the sorts of things that I
would think would be of interest
and what is being suggested
as possible results.
First and foremost,
this is recognized
by the Google image search at
this point as me being interested
in handwriting, which is very
clearly not the case here.
And also while I wasn't expecting
to find poems in newspapers returned
as the result, I was sort
of thinking maybe there would
be some printed poems right.
So again sort of the range and
the gulf of the effectiveness
of these sorts of searches
thus far from something
like contemporary photography to
wanting to find specific types
of items within digitized
collections.
There is though an emerging
body of work in the arts
and humanities interested
in the visual signals
or visual analytics
of textual materials.
Recently the visual page research
team has analyzed visual features
of features of books
of poetry in order
to explore visual meaning
in those print pages.
And in a similar vein the
shapes view or at Bloodaxe,
the poetics of the archive allows
users to explore its archive
by drawing the shape of a poem.
And the search then returns
poems of similar shapes.
And Bloodaxe demonstrates
the potential of thinking
about textual materials visually
particularly the visual is part
of the meaning making of the text.
Both of these projects, however,
begin with a known pre-selected
items from relatively small corpora.
So they're starting when we already
know what we have here is an item
of interest.
So my team and I are extending
visual analysis approaches
for the purposes of
identification and discovery.
And this takes us to part two of my
presentation, sort of the experiment
that we're currently working on.
So our work now looks at whether
we can identify poetic content
in historic newspapers based
only on visual signals.
We're using the chronicling
America collection of newspapers
as our corpus and given
a newspaper page image
from chronicling America we
want to be able to say whether
or not the page features
any poetic content.
And ultimately where the
poetic content is on the page.
So we've been ambitious in
our goal seeking to identify
as little poetic content as a single
couplet quoted in a news article
to finding pages with single or
even multiple full length poems.
To do this work, we've created
a machine learning classifier
to distinguish between
images from newspapers
that feature poetic content
and those that do not.
And this required determining
the visual qualities
that we believe are
important to identifying
or distinguishing poetic content,
translating those visual qualities
into measurable features,
developing algorithms to measure
than those features,
assembling a set of sample images
where we knew the ground
truth, whether
or not the image contained
poetic content or not,
compiling the feature measurements
for both sets of images,
and feeding those values
along with the images status
into an artificial neural network
to help the system learn what values
tend to signal poetic content.
And then finally, testing the
classifier on unlabeled images.
We published early results of this
work in D Live Magazine last summer
and at the classifier training stage
we achieved precision and recall
of just under 91% and 80%
where precision measures how many
times we were correct whenever we
predicted an image
contain poetic content
and recall was measuring how many
times we correctly identified poem
images out of all poem images.
Now these numbers dropped when
we tested the classifier to just
under 75% and 62%, but they weren't
on the less encouraging enough
that we decided to
undertake a larger case study.
We did not want to over fit our
approach for such a small set
of page images that we had
used for this initial test.
And so at this point we know we have
more work to do, but we didn't want
that work to reflect only
this very small sample.
So we've recently undertaken work to
look at a much larger set of images.
Specifically we moved
to a case study
of chronicling America's
newspaper pages from 1836 to 1840.
For this work we have two goals.
One is to scale the system.
And the second is to test
and analyze the accuracy
of the classifier on a
much larger set of data.
We focused on the five
year period 1836 to 1840,
because at the time we started it,
it represented the
first five years worth
of content in chronicling America.
And we knew that we could expect
to find a significant amount
of poetic content in
newspapers from this period.
The first step in the process
was to develop a script
for batch retrieving images
from chronicling America.
And we now have a script that
allows us to retrieve images based
on we're working primarily with
date parameters at this point.
But in the future will likely
add some additional parameters,
as well such as by
newspaper or by state.
For the current study we
retrieved nearly 22,000 images.
What was it at that time all
page images from 1836 to 1840
that chronicling America is growing
at a really tremendous rate now,
so our numbers are - so we're
now already only working
with a subset of those five years.
Getting the page images was
the most straightforward part,
though it was not without
some complication.
Importantly, the system
we've developed for measuring
and evaluating features, though,
doesn't actually process
the entire pages at once.
Instead we process the full page
image as overlapping image snippets
and look to see whether
any of those image snippets
from the page contain poetic content
or features signaling
poetic content.
So in the earlier stage we created
those image snippets manually,
but we've now needed an automated
approach to this process and we need
to be sure that the image snippets
themselves are good in order
to increase the chance that we
will have accurate classifications.
So we developed a process for
evaluating all of the page images
to see if they could be
effectively segmented
and checked each page image
against several set of rules.
And this was something we did
automatically and then broke each
of the pages that passed
into the subsequent snippets.
So approximately 8800 page images
past the segmentation process
and yielded 509,000 image snippets.
In each of these snippets
then undergoes a series
of processes represented by
those images on the screen
and we capture the images
at three different stages.
And those are what we use
to measure the features
and do the feature extraction.
So this work is still
very much in process,
and while we don't have
big results just yet,
hopefully we will by
the end of October.
We do know a few things
at this point.
First is that we've learned about
both historic newspaper pages
as well as about the duplicate of
processes that have brought them
to us in chronicling America.
A variety of factors affect whether
or not a page can be segmented.
These include contrast ratios,
the presence of a number
of illustrations or
the presence of text
or images spanning multiple columns,
and noise in the microfilmed
or digitized image.
Second is that since we know that
we want to know at a high level
of accuracy how good
our classifier is,
so we need to know the ground truth
of the page images and the snippets.
We could have done some sampling,
but at this stage this is very
much a research project and we want
to know at a very accurate level
how accurate the classifier is.
This has meant that I have
manually classified those 8800 pages
so that we can check the
machine classification.
According to the manual
classifications, the work that I did
of those 8800 pages that
passed segmentation 1,678
of them contain poetic content
while just over 7,000 dud not.
But according to our machine
learning classification,
again which is classifying
at the snippet level,
but we can extract the
page metrics from that.
So the machine learning
classification suggests
that there were 4,440 pages
containing poetic content,
which of course is much higher than
my classification and even more
than that, when I compared
my classification
with the machine learning
classification we overlapped only
on 785 pages.
So we know that we have work to do
here and where we're headed next is
to do - so first so we need
to then be able to look
at the snippet level, which means
I'm evaluating those 90,000 snippets
to determine their classification so
we can really do a detailed analysis
on where my classification and
the machine's classification agree
and where they differ and then start
pulling some things out from that.
So this is why it slowed down
a little bit at this stage.
But once we have the
manual classification
and the machine classification
we'll begin the work
of deriving detailed statistics
and thinking about the ways
in which we can further
improve the classifier.
And so that might be techniques
to make sure that we're not quite
as aggressive in returning
snippets as truth.
We can look for over see only
if concurrent snippets are
classified as true, for example.
and then we'll have to see
though how accurate are features
that we think are important
for signaling poetic
content turn out to be.
So we'll be turning to an
understanding of what we get
from our classifier results.
We will be analyzing the data
sets, doing some written analysis,
and doing an early stage look at
how our classifications for length
for newspaper content in languages
other than English compare
with our classifications
of newspapers in English.
Since the 1836 to 1840 set
includes some newspapers in Spanish,
we can start testing this idea
that an image based approach
for textual materials
should be language agnostic.
Okay. So in the longer term
then and I'll hear both.
So when I created these slides
last week I felt compelled to talk
in fairly broad terms, but
only yesterday I learned
that our research team has
received IMLS research grant funding
to continue our work, and we
have a sure course for that work.
We're embarking on a new partnership
with colleagues at the University
of Virginia with whom we
seek to extend our software
across a more diverse range
of digitized newspapers
and textual forms, and to assess the
broader potential of image analysis
as a methodology for image
classification identification
discovery and retrieval
and digital libraries.
Given the visual distinctiveness and
poetry in the immediate potential
for scholarly impact, we
seek to refine our methods
on poetic content, but now
also to a number of boundaries,
including geographic,
temporal and linguistic.
And I can say more about the work
that we're interested in doing
in the course of that
grant, but our hope is
that this work ultimately will
affect how we develop digital
collections, both prerelease and
post-release of the collection.
We seek to develop new strategies
and workflows for librarians
and archivists to identify
and classify materials
and to facilitate researchers
abilities to pose new questions
of digitized collections.
Ultimately we hope this
work might also materialize
and more creative interfaces such
as that on the Bloodaxe archive
that allow users to
query collections
in ways beyond the text based search
or browsing conventional
organizational schemes
such as date and publication.
Before we can get to
those interfaces, however,
we both need to create the
underlying data as well
as broaden our sense of what's
possible with the collections
that we build and this will require
us to work with both text and image
as well as to see text as image.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, good.
Hello everybody.
I really appreciate being here.
You know, I'm one of those people
who were basically a
librarian through and through.
I have a bachelor in
library science,
so meaning at 18 years old I
decided to become a librarian.
So [laughs] being at the Library
of Congress and, you know,
speaking here is I mean I'm from the
Philippines, so it's such a big deal
to be here so if there's
anyone watching.
Yeah, I'm here.
And it's awesome.
[ Clapping ]
Okay, enough about me.
Let's talk about virtual
reunification,
which is one of my passions.
So first I'd like to promise this
conversation by talking about,
you know, that digitization has
become a fundamental responsibility.
I mean when I say this occasionally
I'll get some nasty looks
from other people, because they
don't appreciate this idea.
But, you know, we have to wake up.
This is - institutions are
expected to be doing digitization.
I know that there are resource
disparities, but, you know,
I teach introduction to
archives and I'm now expected
to teach my students in
putting digitization a spark
of archival practice.
So this is part of our
realities right now
as cultural heritage institutions.
With digitization we
facilitate discovery.
In fact, there are
studies that indicate
that having digital surrogate will
help institutions discover the
actual artifact, will
also bring people
to use collections more broadly.
We are redefining relationships
with our patrons
by providing digital products.
We are rethinking our work
as heritage institutions
and it also redefines what it means
to perform library
archives and museum work.
And it's also this
conversation of color convergence
and collaboration has been
happening even before digitization.
But I think digitization
is one way to ensure
that institutions are
truly collaborating
by sharing resources and expertise.
So the way we've handled
dispersed collections
in the archival community
in the past is
that first we acknowledge them
in our finding a saying you know
this collection is also found
in five other institutions
sometimes we're comprehensive,
sometimes we're not.
Another thing at the theoretical
level we've tried to expand notions
of provenance ownership
and what it means
to have records in our custodies.
And finally, we are using technical
standards and tools in reconnecting
and linking collections together.
Here's one quote from
2001 by Jeanette Bastian.
She says "Standards such as
EAD now offer the potential
of virtually reuniting
fragmented collections
and relating distributed
collections through the
on line linking of finding aids."
And she's talking about this
in the context of the records
of the U.S. Virgin Islands.
So move to more contemporary
times we hear the term
"virtual reunification,"
which is, you know,
a very short definition would be
allowing dispersed collections
to be brought together.
It's a highly collaborative
endeavor.
Okay. It will involve multiple
institutions, multiple scholars
in various disciplines,
and multiple expertise
within cultural heritage work.
It harnesses the (inaudible)
of the digital.
The problem with many
dispersed collections is
that it's almost entirely
impossible to reunite them
in their physical formats,
because one,
you encounter geographic
limitations,
things are in far places.
Physically sometimes materials
are, you know, in different formats
that are quite challenging
to be brought together
in their physical form since they
say that finally with, you know,
digital surrogates we can
bring things together.
It also facilitates cultural
diplomacy in some projects
of virtual reunification
projects in Europe, for instance.
You know, it involves
multiple institutional
or national institutions.
Here's some examples of
virtual reunification projects
that there's many out
there, but these are some.
My favorites is the
Walt Whitman Archive
and I'm sure it's familiar to many.
It brings, you know, the work of
one person and also, you know,
from various institutions and
trying to do multiple ways
of engaging with the material.
Reunification or bringing
together the whole
of collections has its deep
roots in the analog world,
specifically in the humanities.
So, you know, in art history there's
such a thing as catalog [inaudible]
or in music complete works
or in literature you have
critical or scholarly editions.
And in history we have
or which is more related
to archival work historical
editions.
So, you know, you have
historians going
through different repositories
trying to collect all writings
of Thomas Jefferson, for instance.
So there's a long scholarly
trajectory
in bringing together collections.
What I've noticed about virtual
reunification is that there's lack
of attention to photographic
materials.
There are projects out there looking
at image processing and
pattern recognition.
There are projects that, you
know, would exhibit photographs
for instance, but they're
not at the particular scale
where you have them
from all over the place.
Different institutions, multiple
stakeholders, and just truly,
you know, bringing them and doing
scholarly work with those materials.
It's also touted as a
way to do repatriation,
meaning returning collections to
source communities by digital means.
But there's no clear explanation
of what it really truly means
to return something that's digital.
More on success, but
less on barriers.
When I read the literature
on this subject people are still
laboratory saying, yea we did it.
It's difficult.
Congratulations to us
because we've done it.
But actually we learn from
barriers from projects that tell us
that these are the problems
that we've encountered.
So that when we do it again,
we know things to expect.
And also it's unclear about inter
institutional collaboration.
When ten institutions
are involved and one
of those is let's say a historical
society and in one county
versus the Smithsonian, there's
an imbalance in terms of resources
and prestige in that project.
So there's a lot to, you know, be
done and discussed in this area.
And in the world of digital
repatriation, anthropologists
and people who study digital
repatriation have acknowledged
that there's some problem around
the notion of returning copies
of artifacts to Native
American communities.
Is it really return?
Is it really repatriation
if you're providing copies,
no matter how good the
resolution might be?
But at the same time,
not all communities want the actual
artifacts to be returned to them,
that many communities are
quite happy with, you know,
digital surrogates that they
can use in the classrooms
and in their communities.
So there's really not one
solution to this issue.
And, you know, where does the return
happen and for whom is it done?
Is it for the institution?
Is it for the community or is it for
the scholar facilitating the return?
So my project looked at the
photographs taken in the Philippines
in the early 1900s by colonial
administrator that was assigned
in the Philippines, Dean Wooster.
He was a zoologist and
because of his interest
in zoology he started going
around the Philippines
to document the different
indigenous groups of the country
and in the process managed to amass
a cache of photographic materials.
Here are some examples
of the photos.
And here's more.
So the rationale is
that for us to be able
to manage this new territory
called the Philippines,
we need to understand its
people and more importantly,
we need to understand their
resources so we can trade.
So that was the whole premise
around the ethnographic surveys
that he did in the early 1900s.
Now the photographs of
Wooster are currently are
in more than ten institutions.
But I looked at ten
institutions for this study.
There's an effort to consolidate
them since the 1970s by doing,
you know, like a union catalog, of
sort, for where they are located.
There is a research demand
on these photographs and it's
in various stages of digitization
and there's some funding
available for this.
And yet reunification
is not happening.
So I said this is probably an ideal
case to study and examine, you know,
in an in a context where
something is likely
to happen, yet it's not happening.
What's stopping it from happening?
That was my particular
question at that time.
So I went through ten institutions
that collected these photographs.
Two of those are I would classify
as Natural History Museum,
Four our anthropology and
archaeological museums.
Two are archival institutions
or archives
and two our special collections.
You will see and I
will get back to this
that in these multiple institutions,
you know, the photos are
of different formats and
different types of state or stages
in terms of digitization.
But so, you know, you go back
to the idea of, you know,
if you want to bring something
together that's dispersed,
who decides on behalf
of the communities
when only institutions are talking?
And how do you display
indigenous images when, you know,
if you want to produce
some something scholarly?
Another problem that I've
seen is that, you know,
there are many dimensions
to dispersion.
When you say I'm reunifying
something that's dispersed,
so are you referring to, you
know, the physical distance
that they're scattered
in various places?
Are you talking about
temporal of dispersion,
because they were dispersed
at different moments in time?
Provenantial, I'm using provenance
from the archival sense in terms
of the chain of custody and
ownership to these materials.
Or is it material?
The challenge is material.
So here's one visualization
elementary one
that I created for myself.
You know, like to show
you some notion
of dispersion that's geographic.
It's in multiple places.
It could also be provenantial, so
in one institution the material is,
you know, categorized as a
collection by Frederick Wooster,
the son of the photographer who then
donated it to the American Museum
of Natural History and then later
the negatives were transferred
to the University of Michigan
Museum of Anthropology.
So, you know, provenance
as well is quite dispersed.
It's sometimes it doesn't
just go in one direction.
So it's also temporal.
They were given to this
various institutions
at different moments in time.
So there's that, you know, the
earliest collection that I found was
when at the National
Anthropological Archives.
So and also material.
Sometimes the photograph
would be in a scrapbook,
sometimes it's a lantern slide.
Even if you compare two
scrapbooks images are, you know,
put in different chronological
order or different parts of the same
or two different scrapbooks.
So there's a lot of researchers
are interested in the meaning
around the changing
of this, you know,
chronological representation
of the photographs.
And also among institutions
that I've interviewed,
they seem to have this
notion of, you know,
so we can show these
photographs to everybody.
And so we have to make
sure that not, you know,
we are more responsible around, you
know, who gets to see the image.
So as far as these institutions are
concerned, they have to see it first
because they need to
work on the collection
and then the source communities,
of course the different
indigenous groups
that that would take
ownership of these images.
And then researchers and scholars
and then maybe the Filipino
immigrant communities or living
in the U.S. and then the
general public the last.
So it's a different
notion of access.
I know that many information
professionals are very much in love
with universal unfiltered,
unhindered access,
but it's just not the case for
ethnographic collections with ties
to Indigenous communities.
So, finally,.
I am leaving you with
three questions.
The first is what does it
mean to assemble the whole?
You know, as I said earlier there
are many dimensions to dispersion.
Does it mean getting all of those?
They mention together
in one representational
kind of digital project.
What is the object of reunification?
Sometimes we actually
care about relationships,
fixing relationships
with communities.
Is that what we want that
ultimately the outcome is
that we have good relationships
with communities
that the material recombination
or assembly
of these things are
a way towards that.
Another is reunification
is a solution.
What really is the problem?
Is this sometimes, you know, I
hear of availability of technology
that it will solve things, that
will do a lot of things for us.
But is this a solution
in search of a problem?
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> This one, got it.
Okay.
Oh. Can you duplicating or can
you split the screen by chance?
Sorry about that.
You think a web developer
would know how to [laughs].
Thank you.
[laughs] All right, perfect.
Well, on a personal level I
may be the most surprising
and unlikely person today as not
long ago I sat in the library
to escape the beautiful chaos
of my then 1-year-old daughter.
I was combing through programming
books to build an app of my own.
I had recently resigned
from a ten year career
as an accountant an auditor
to pursue a passion
for web development.
Shortly thereafter I
started my current dream job
as a web developer
for This universe.org.
So it's fitting I introduce
you to a surprising tool
that will unlock the
data of your collections
in unlikely ways you may
not imagine this universe.
This universe is the world's
largest most popular platform
for people powered research and
one of 26 Zooniverse team members.
Many also with unorthodoxed
backgrounds, including Ph.D.s
in astronomy, the humanities,
ecology and philosophy.
There is an amazing team of
developers and data scientists
as well as education and
outreach ambassadors.
Today I'll introduce you to the
university our diverse projects
and focus on transcription projects
and give you a brief overview
of our project builder.
It all started with
Galaxy Zoo in 2007.
Like many scientists and
likely many here today,
two astronomers had more
data than they could process.
They had over a million galaxies
to classify before they
could even use the data
to ask the interesting
questions about our universe.
One of them remarkably
classified 50,000 image galaxies
over a month classifying
morning day and night,
but would likely go insane or spend
the rest of their life classifying
to complete the data set.
Now the pattern recognition required
for the initial classifying
humans excel at,
while computers yet do none.
Their solution was
to harness the power
of crowd sourcing with Galaxy Zoo.
They employed the general public
to go and review the images
and classify them as a spiral
or elliptical with a tutorial,
if needed, and the
results were incredible.
There were 50 million
classifications during its first
year alone with over
150,000 people contributing.
Eventually it was determined that
the crowd sourced consensus was
as good as classifications provided
by professional astronomers,
showing that the crowd
gets it right.
The research team has
since published
over 40 peer reviewed
publications including some
where volunteers are
listed as co-authors.
These are just regular
everyday volunteers.
Galaxy Zoo accomplished research
otherwise thought impossible.
And it gets more exciting.
In the upper left here we
have a legendary guitarist
for Queen, Brian May.
He's also a Ph.D. astronomer.
And an avid Galaxy Zoo participant.
And he inspired others like Hannifin
Ukcal [SP] there in the upper right.
She's a teacher in the Netherlands.
She classified the
work to spiral galaxy
in the finner image towards the top.
But ask what's the object below it?
The researchers looked into
her question and it turns
out it's a galaxy sized gas
cloud driven by a black hole
in the neighborhood
neighboring galaxy
that recently shifted
from active to quiet.
Scientists knew of it, but had
never captured the phenomenon.
Hanie was the first person
in history to witness it
and it was aptly named
after her, which illustrates
that the more people you
engage in your project,
the more likely someone will make
an amazing serendipitous discovery.
So each project has a
forum that we call talk.
Talk is where volunteers can
communicate with each other as well
with the researchers or experts.
In this project the first
discussion is for specific images.
Next is general questions and
there's specific discussions
that are unique to this project.
Now, Talk is where we often see
these serendipitous discoveries
like Hanie's Ververs.
And a key to a successful project
is that the research team engages
with its volunteers through Talk.
This is our current
landing page of projects
and since 2007 this universe has
expanded to over 45 active projects
with several hundred
researchers that have led
to over 100 peer reviewed
publications.
The Galaxy Zoo papers
alone have had thousands
of citations in reuse of the data.
Galaxy is doing its story
encapsulates three important points
I'd like to emphasize.
First, engagement with
volunteers will equate
to the success of a project.
Secondly, crowd sourcing is
both about classifications
and serendipitous discoveries.
And third, crowd sourcing leads
to accurate and reliable results.
Science Gossip is a
transcription project
that bridges the citizens
scientists of the Victorian period
with the citizen scientists
of today.
For computers and cameras
citizen scientists had
to draw what they saw.
But those drawings have been
locked away in the pages
of those Victorian periodicals.
Until today, through Science Gossip
volunteers can help classify those
drawings unlocking the
origins of citizen science.
What may have taken a diligent
historian over ten years,
volunteers for [inaudible]
to accomplish in one.
It's accomplishing research
otherwise thought impractical.
One volunteer found the left image
an illustration by Mabel Rhodes
on the anatomy of the
wrathfully and asked in Talk
if it was the first
female contributor?
And her question inspired
the community.
They discovered numerous women
engravers and illustrators,
including many previously
uncredited.
One volunteer's question
brought the collection to life
in an amazing and unexpected way.
Penguin watch is one of
my personal favorites.
You get to spy on penguins
for science.
You tag penguins in remote regions
to help us understand their lives,
the environment and the
effects of climate change.
A contest for penguin
watch volunteers was held
and the winner got to
go to the Antarctic.
And you could see the
winner of that contest
in that lower right jumping
into the Antarctic seas.
And I am not sure all of our
volunteers share that level
of enthusiasm, [laughs]
but the number one reason
that volunteers do
participate is simply
to contribute to scientific
progress.
Runner up reasons are that
they're fascinated on a project
or that it's just plain fun.
We have over 1.5 million
registered volunteers
across 237 countries ranging in
age from five to 95 years old.
It's a wonderfully diverse group,
all making real contributions
to science.
Snapshots Serengeti is another
one of my personal favorites.
Volunteers have classified images
from hundreds of camera traps
in Serengeti National Park
providing a powerful new window
into Africa's most
elusive wildlife species.
It was launched in 2012 and
it's been incredibly successful.
In the first three days alone there
were over a million classifications.
It processed an 18
month backlog of images.
And there's a related publication
that showed that the crowd is
as good as experts in
consensus scenarios
or were 97% accurate
compared to the 98% accuracy
of experts and other scenarios.
Again the crowd gets it right.
And personally I now know the
difference between a hartebeest
and a wildebeest and this
project is just plain fun.
To elaborate more on
what I mean by consensus,
Snapshot Serengeti has 25
volunteers classify an image before
retiring it.
Unless the first five say
it's blank or 10 agreed,
thereby reaching a consensus.
Now this image is pretty
straightforward, and as you can see
in the lower right volunteers are
currently all in agreement so far
that there is one giraffe
in this image.
[laughs] While this
image is challenging.
One volunteer thinks
there are four wildebeests
and other three are asterisks.
One wildebeest and others Buffalo.
With certain images it's just
not possible to get consensus.
In which case 25 people will
classify the image before
it's retired.
Now even experts can't
agree on these images.
And though these images are
the minority, most or over 70%
of images are retired with
the consensus before getting
to the 25 classification maximum.
So now we'll focus
on some transcription projects
starting with Anno Tate.
Anno Tate is a collaboration with
the Tate Museums and Archives
and it's a museums of
the web top prize winner.
In addition to creating art, many
artists wrote diaries and letters,
and made sketchbooks
that contain rich details
about their lives and
creative processes.
Volunteers transcribe these
documents from the Tate collection
and reveal the secret
lives of artists.
I'd like to have the artist's
works open in one window
and classify in another window.
It gives a whole new
appreciation for the art
and the artists themselves.
For documents such as
this OCR doesn't work,
which is why we need
to transcribe them.
Transcription can be
quite challenging.
It's not as straightforward
as looking at a penguin,
but we try to make it
as straightforward and
simple as possible.
For NSA we utilize the transcription
method I'm going to refer to as line
by line and we don't ask volunteers
to transcribe an entire page.
We do not ask them
to even necessarily
transcribe it in her sentence.
We simply ask them to transcribe one
visual line at a time that they feel
that they can do in confidence.
This creates a quality
collective efforts.
Each lines xy coordinates
and related transcription
is then compared
with an algorithm creating
hopefully consensus
and vastly reducing
the need for experts.
To date the average rate of
accuracy for a line transcribed
by multiple people
on Anno Tate is 95%.
This rate of accuracy is in line
with estimates on OCR accuracy,
which are 94% for grayscale
and 97% for bitonal.
So accuracy in line with OCR on
documents that can't use OCR.
Again showing that the
crowd gets it right.
In collaboration with the
Folger Shakespeare Library here
in Washington DC and other
transcription projects
that we love is Shakespeare's World.
Volunteers transcribe
handwritten documents
by Shakespeare's contemporaries
and help us understand his
amazing life and times.
As a symbol or a line
by line process,
but there's added complexity for
the type of historical documents.
Now what we've learned with this
project as well as others is
that if you have a
great UI for volunteers,
then they can accomplish complex
and difficult transcription.
Again it helps to break
the transcription process
down to an approachable level.
So documents are divided
between recipes and letters.
And for those interested in
delicious dishes or juicy gossip
from Shakespeare's time, I
personally enjoy the recipes.
They can be tough,
but it's fascinating.
There's also a wonderful blog with
Shakespeare's World, just like many
of our projects that gives updates
and shares great stories
from the project.
The next transcription project
is decoding the civil war.
You can witness the United
States Civil War by transcribing
and deciphering messages and codes
from the United States
military telegraph.
Including there's one
telegram from Abraham Lincoln
to Mary Todd two weeks before
his death updating her on the war
after a meeting with General Grant.
It's incredibly interesting and then
there's other telegraphs requesting
whiskey or clean underwear.
It runs the gamut and it's
a fascinating perspective
into the people's lives
of this remarkable time
in our country's history.
Now as you hopefully can see in
the animation this is a variation
on the method I previously
mentioned.
Here volunteers underline
a line and then transcribe.
We ask volunteers to do an entire
telegraph before proceeding.
An additional method that we worked
on years ago in collaboration
with the New York Public
Library is Scribe.
The method with Scribe is that
one volunteer marks the document
structure and then
the same volunteer
or a different volunteer can
do the work of transcribing.
There's also a verification process.
Scribe is open source
like everything we do is.
I'd encourage you if you want to do
a transcription project on your own,
I was [inaudible] at the University.
I thought Scribe might be
a very useful tool for you.
There's also a method
that the Smithsonian uses
where one volunteer
might transcribe,
a different volunteer would review
and then an expert would review
and there's feedback
all along that cycle.
And there's no right
or wrong method.
The best method depends
on the project.
So coming back to decoding the
Civil War, this was entirely built,
this was recently launched and
built within our project builder.
Now a little over a year ago we
launched the project builder.
It's an easy to use,
browser based interface
to create your project,
and it's incredible.
We're really proud of it.
Right now anyone can build their
own project for free in hours.
Go to [inaudible] click build a
project and you're on your way.
It's that simple.
There's an overview.
I'm going to give an overview,
but there's a detailed tutorial
and there are message
boards on line,
if you'd like to try it yourself.
So this is a screenshot from
within the project builder.
Don't worry about the details shown.
My intent is just to give you a
general feel for the interface.
In the far left menu from top
to bottom you have a project -
what we refer to as product
section, a workflow section
and a subject set sections.
I'll start with subject sets.
It's likely your collection.
Typically in our case images, though
we're experimenting with video.
You can upload your subjects
into the project builder
or we do support externally
hosted images.
Can include metadata, like your
internal IDs and other information,
which can either be shown
or hidden from volunteers.
And once you have your subject set
into the product builder you
could then create what we refer
to as a workflow.
It's the sequence of tasks
that you ask volunteers to do.
And we have many types of
tasks, including text tasks,
especially useful for
transcription projects,
a drawing task, a drop down task.
Some are behind an experimental
flag, so in which case ask
and we'll enable it for you.
Also within the project,
in the workflow editor you set
the retirement for a subject.
Just how many times it's classified
for is no longer shown
to volunteers.
So once you have a subject set
and a workflow you've completed
the core of the project.
Now here we see what a
volunteer sees while classifying
within the Notes for Nature project.
Notes of Nature is where volunteers
transcribes specimen labels
that we recently relaunched
after rebuilding
within the project builder.
I work closely with this project.
It's been a wonderful experience,
has an incredible research team.
And what you can see
here are two text tasks
to where a volunteer
can type the specimen,
collect your name and number.
And then three drop down tasks
enter the month day and year.
All within what we refer
to as a combo task.
And this is an example
of what you can build
and what a volunteer would then see.
Within the product builder you
can also add other collaborators
or people to help you.
You can add content for
your project lining page,
you can create a team page or
research page to give more detail
about what you're looking
to accomplish.
You can create tutorials
field guides in many courses
to help volunteers classify it.
You could set up your talk
for the incredible serendipity
I mentioned earlier happens.
And you can export
aspects of your project,
including boundary
classifications either
on day one, [inaudible] or whenever.
There's a review process to
be featured on the main page,
but as soon as you build your
project you can share a link
with it to anyone.
A successful project articulates
their purpose well as workflows
that are as straightforward
and simple as possible.
Detailed help for volunteers and
an active research team on talk
which I can't - it
helps significantly.
So the Zooniverse is expanding
at an accelerating rate
with exciting challenges ahead,
especially with transcription
projects which we love
to collaborate with you on.
We're constantly working
with machinery and experts
to further their research as well
as make sure we're not wasting
our volunteers precious time.
And we're actively improving
the Zooniverse on mobile.
We're open source.
Check us out when you get home.
Zooniverse works and
we want you to join us.
Help us accomplish science
otherwise thought impossible.
Unlike your data or someone else's.
We won't make you jump in the
Antarctic seas, but you may end
up with a galactic sized
gas cloud in there for you.
And on a final note,
we're also thrilled
to announce two upcoming open
calls for partners with text
or audio transcription projects
needing custom tools or interface.
It's hard to express how
excited we are about this.
These open calls are made possible
by [inaudible] from the Institute
of Museum and Library Services
for a three year effort
to better support this community.
As part of this effort we
will take lessons learned
through these new custom build
projects to improve the tools
that we offer to all
through the project builder.
So thank you for your time today.
[ Applause ]
>> So we're going to
have time for questions.
So if Liz and Ricky if you
want to join us up here.
Doing this we have about
15 minutes for questions,
and if you have a question you're
in the audience raise your hand
and we'll have volunteers with
the mics that will find you.
I see we have one hand
raised in the back already.
Also on Twitter, if you are
following along you can tweet your
questions using the
hash tag "as data."
So, again,, we'll take
questions for about 15 minutes.
I'm going to mention this
quickly because we might -
because we'll just break
for lunch right after.
We're going to break until
1:30 after the question round.
And just a reminder you have to
if you leave the building you have
to pass through security
to get back in.
So come back, plan for that
if you leave the building.
If you don't want to
leave the building,
you can go to our main cafeteria
in the Madison building
via some tunnels.
And if you meet by the
information desk then a Library
of Congress staff will help
you go through those tunnels.
So just that quick
piece before we start.
Do we have somebody with a
microphone in the back here.
Yes, please go ahead.
You want to start back here?
>> Hello. I'm [inaudible], I'm
from the Smithsonian libraries,
the Smithsonian transcription
Center and the National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture.
We launched recently a transcription
project transcribing the Freedman
Spieler Records, a reconstruction
era, a group of federal documents
and we launched it just a
little over a month ago.
My question to the last speaker is
what kind of incentives do you offer
to your volunteers to
continue with the process?
How do you deal with
some of the difficulties
of the challenges with
the transcription.
What kind of system do you
have to keep them going.
>> I can [inaudible].
Okay.
So, yes, the transcription
is challenging.
So it's difficult to
keep volunteers engaged.
We have found that talk in
the community that builds
around these projects is
really the strongest way
to keep people engaged.
And that not only helps
people ask questions or get
through the difficult
challenges that might be related
to that specific transcription
project,
but it also helps people
explore interesting ideas
that they may have.
Because usually the people
who are getting involved
in these transmission projects
have their interest in the material
of course, and they may have,
you know, they come to it
with interesting ideas
or ways perspectives.
And when you have people sharing
this together through the art form
of talk it just builds on itself.
And that's what keeps people engaged
I think to the highest degree.
We don't have any other, like I mean
occasionally our research team might
have like prizes or, you
know, giveaways or whatnot,
but that's really not
the core of it.
I mean in all honestly, one of the
smaller points is like the people
who participate and continue to
participate just because they want
to further the purpose
of the project.
So it's really a lot of our
volunteers are primarily motivated
by their altruism, so and they
get kind of hooked into it.
And once they get a little practice
transcribing they often continue to.
Hope that answered.
>> Great we have another
question here.
Right here?
>> Yes.
>> Go ahead.
>> This question is also
for the last speaker.
For the tools that you mentioned
and I'm actually really interested
in your audio tool that I
think is going to come out.
Are you limited to what
language you can apply this to?
Like if I have a collection in say
Czech, could that work on that?
>> Well so I'd have to
check - so I'm just kind
of just thinking out loud here.
We could build like a UI
that could support that.
That would be a custom.
Currently I'm not sure if
we have that capability,
but that would be a
custom project that is,
you know, potentially feasible.
We have lots of plans,
including internationalization.
So if we were to incorporate that on
like a global site level it might
also complement a specific project
or collection.
You said in Czech?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, so you know I don't
think we will be able to - well.
Support that today.
But the technological
barriers don't seem too large.
That's the wonderful thing about
the recent funding is we can explore
these types of challenges that
much more easily now going forward.
So I'd have to check to give
you a specific direct answer
of what we can do today,
but if we can't we hope
to in the future [laughs].
>> We have a couple
questions down here.
>> Hi, I also am interested in
the project of the last speaker
and I'm coming at it
from a peculiar angle,
which is that I've spent
some time as a volunteer
in senior living residences
and one of the issues there is
that everybody is limited
in what they can do.
So some of the projects that
have been very successful
in that environment until now have
been seniors doing English language
teaching using Skype with
students are from around the world.
And that's super successful and
I can imagine that some version
of this could apply in
that environment as well.
But I'm just thinking
is there a possibility
that there could be let's say
a simpler interface overlaid
on what you have now, so that people
with a lot of time on their hands,
but limited abilities could
be effective and useful
and have some productive
activity in their own lives?
>> Yeah. Absolutely and the projects
really run, there's a wide range
of difficulty in our projects.
Some currently up there right now
and actually I guess I
should be embarrassed
to admit this, but I'm not.
My favorite is like
the penguin watch
and Snapshot Serengeti
are very approachable.
And while some certainly are
more complicated like some
of the astronomy projects,
some of the transcription
projects there are some
that I think would be very
accessible to, you know,
like the people that
you're working with.
And sometimes we will, you know,
we do all educational outreach too,
so we do try to consider
making the projects accessible
to as many people as we can.
But that's, yeah, that's
an interesting,
you know, area of opportunity.
I'm not sure if we've
fully considered,
but I would think right now there
actually would be some projects
that might apply.
>> Another question here.
Down here, down here.
>> Hi. I work for a data storage
company, so often we think
about how we're going
to store all that stuff.
So all of you store
mountains of data, right.
You're all working
with that all the time.
So my question would be how do
you possibly store all of that?
And then how long do you store it?
And then how is it similar
or different for each of you,
because you have such different
projects in a lot of ways.
>> [laughs] So for our project.
At this point we have a
manageable amount of data,
because we're maintaining the
images after we process them
and then the featured data sets.
I'm at an institution that
has both a data repository -
has a data repository.
And the expectation that the
institution will be the place
that manages that data, so and we
have a number of systems in place,
and so we work with
Deepen as one example.
So we'll have to see and since we're
not - our needs are not necessarily
for - it's not preservation forever,
we're looking at managing the data
for reproducibility
over X number of years.
And I think our plan at
this point is five years.
So since we are not the
collector of the original images
and we don't need to maintain the
digital images, it's not to say
that we don't have we may
not run into some challenges,
but I feel like institutionally
we're
in a pretty good place for that.
>> Well with me it's the same.
I do have copies of some of the
photos that I study and I believe
in lots of copies keep stuff safe.
So I put them in multiple
hard drives.
I also have copies that, you know,
I use for just basic
processing and work.
So I have a digital file that's,
you know, better resolution and,
you know, more preservation copied.
So I teach introduction to
digital curation, so I kind of have
to follow what I teach,
which is, you know,
like the [inaudible]
model of doing things.
But, yeah, but I'm not - I
definitely don't have collections
of the level of a repository
that would make, you know,
large [inaudible] materials,
such a daunting task.
>> And we actually also we're
not necessarily responsible
for maintaining the, like the
images or the collections over time.
Someone who's going to create a
project they're really the ones
who are responsible for over the
long-term maintaining and storing
and organizing those -
in our case often images.
But just from a like a technical
standpoint, we use AWOS,
Amazon Web Services to host
a lot of our information.
So I guess we're in the
cloud for the most part.
And actually I'm a front end
developer, so I'm somewhat ignorant
in terms of the entire back
end picture or ops picture.
But. I think, yeah,
essentially it sounds
like we're actually all
kind of somewhat similar.
[laughs]
>> All right, so I think we
have time for one more question.
And I have one up here in the back.
>> Hi this question is for Ricky.
Ricky, I was very intrigued
by your grid
to analyze the virtual
reunification, and I wonder if the,
you know, the providential
geographical et cetera.
I wonder if these have been
used for Indigenous collections
or is it typically for
Anthropological field work.
>> So. The model that I did was
primarily to explain the complexity
of virtual reunification
for mainly people who are
in charge of collections.
Because I do tell them that,
you know, if you are trying
to capture the whole
you need to have some -
at this point I don't
think it's possible.
So, you know, to consider this
is a way to analyze the problem
for yourself, and, you
know, create representations
that would somewhat
allow the representation
of these different
aspects of dispersion.
Now, whether - so this is mainly
for [inaudible] collections
that a project that's
recently funded
by IMLS called Valuing our Scans.
And this goes to communities
are looking at the impact
of digitized collections once,
you know, they're downloaded.
Because we are quite good at
doing research on like how do we,
you know, discoverability,
you know, when you search
for something how quickly
can you get
at something that you're
looking for.
But what happens once the image is
taken by a person into their homes?
What happens?
Do they keep it?
Do they use it for something else?
You know, what's the impact of this?
So I'm taking that model more to
inform my research on that project.
So, yes, this is an
ongoing conversation,
if I would put it that way.
So, you know, I'm definitely
learning a lot since I move on.
>> OK. Thank you.
So we'll have to break
here for lunch.
Again, meet back here at 1:30
and leave time for security.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us LOC.gov.